good morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you are joining us
from welcome to simply learn we are
honored to have you join us today for
need for speed why shift to agile with
your host Jeff Allen my name is Richard
and after the central be mostly in the
background helping jeff until the last
15 minutes will help with the questions
and answers agile in today's world and
project management this is one of the
biggest buzz words out there agile both
for having a successful business and for
having a successful career if you do not
know Jeff Allen Jeff is a founder of
power payment get out of debt system
lead instructor trainer and coach 4pm
for over half a decade in the sort of
areas 19 plus years as a consultant and
agile waterfall and project management
we're honored to have Jeff join us today
for those who aren't familiar with this
form of webinar I want to introduce you
to your dashboard or control panel if
everyone could locate your dashboard and
then locate the question module right
now we have your your audio your mics
turned off because we had everybody
talking in the background we have all
kinds of background noises so you want
to make the question module your best
friend and ask your questions in here if
you can go ahead and just say hello or
hi let us know you're excited to be here
let jeff know you're excited to have
them now we appreciate that now we can
also test our audio make sure it's
working correctly hello Ramya thank you
for being here great to have you Cynthia
there's there is a shank excellent great
to have everybody on board so if you
have any personal or direct questions on
your own career this is a great place to
ask that or about your business we have
a professional here that's you know good
great free tutor is right now you know
has some good questions if you hear
something awesome brilliant or
interesting and you want to share in
your social channels whatever your
social channels are Facebook Linkedin
tweet you can use the hashtag SL
webinars that way people can find it and
you'll make them wish they were here you
didn't come here to listen to me I'm
proud to introduce Jeff will be your
host for Need for Speed why shift a July
go ahead and sit back relax have a cup
of coffee tea or if it's evening where
you're at maybe a glass of wine and
enjoy it's an honor for me to have you
hand this over to Jeff thank you and
happy learning hello Jeff and welcome to
simply learn I Richard that was a nice
introduction thanks thank you I'm going
to go ahead mute myself and let you take
over well welcome everybody I'm glad
you're here I enjoy doing these because
well for a lot of reasons one is is I
kind of have an idea where you are in
life if you are sitting in on this
webinar and I love the fact that folks
like to kind of owners in own their role
of project managers because when you do
you get eager about you know learning
skills and tools and techniques in what
I love about project management is that
not only can you learn how to be the
go-to project manager in your
organization but by becoming that kind
of a professional you become a better
person project management is not just
about getting a project done it's about
becoming a person that can lead a
project so that can be done and you know
if you think about it projects is all
about getting stuff done and everybody
has to get stuff done whether it's a
work or in our avocations or with our
families and so anyway it's exciting for
me and our topic today is the need for
speed and why shift the agile and you
know we picked I guess just a few things
that we're going to touch on on you know
we could go for hours on this and we
would love it and would be exciting but
some of the things we're going to touch
on is we're going to just make sure that
we're all kind on the same page when it
comes to what projects are what project
management is we're going to talk a
little bit about the differences between
waterfall or traditional project
management and agile project management
we're going
talk about why shifting the agile has
become such a huge thing in the world
today particularly when it comes to the
IT world and software development we're
going to talk a little bit about
adopting agile and an organization will
touch on some of the failure modes that
are a part of that and we'll touch on
some key strategies for what a smooth
and successful agile transition effort
actually looks like so let's go ahead
and let's just remind ourselves that
project management like I said a minute
ago is really just about getting stuff
done and people have needed to get stuff
done for a very long time now think
about some things like the pyramids in
Egypt or the Roman aqueducts or
cathedrals in Europe or the First
Transcontinental railway in America and
you can probably think about some things
in whatever part of the world you're in
as well these are projects there were
things that needed to get done and they
all have some unique characteristics
about them you know a project has a
definite beginning and a definite end
and it results in something unique and
project management historically has been
practiced informally but it eventually
began to emerge as a distinct profession
around the mid 20th century so prior to
then projects were pretty much managed
on an ad hoc basis there were some tools
and things that were used you know some
charts and reporting techniques and some
meetings and things like that but when
we get to the 1950s things begin to
change and that's kind of the time that
we mark the beginning of modern project
management and this is where core
engineering fields came together in
order to work as one you know to
collaborate and actually intelligently
plan execute and get stuff done so like
I mentioned you
definitionally a project is something
that is an effort that results in
something unique and so when we talk
about which meant we are not talking
about operations it's not the routine
stuff and whether we're building a
building expanding sales into a new
market developing a software application
whatever these are all examples of
projects and there are basically two
approaches the project management
there's waterfall or traditional and
there's a jet and at a very high level
here the differences between the two so
traditional or waterfall project
management is a plan driven approach and
it favors projects with clear
requirements in the creation of a master
plan on the front end and then once that
plan is approved an execution begins
measuring the actual results against the
plan in order to determine the health of
the project now agile focuses on
projects that are unclear and or have
changing requirements and so the focus
is on delivering value to the customer
in short frequent iterations rather than
having a big master plan on the front
end and so the measure of success and
agile changes so we're not measuring
results against the plan what we're
doing is we're measuring results against
what the customer or the product owner
wants delivered and that can be in very
short iterations it can be from one week
to six weeks with most of them being in
two to four weeks now how do you know
whether a project should be managed
using the waterfall approach or the
agile approach because neither one is
better than the other it's actually
which approach should be used in order
to
the most successful outcome so we put
together this little chart right here
and you can see that at the bottom left
corner we have a box labeled simple so
when we're thinking about the
requirements of the project and the
technology involved in that box right
there we're close to agreement and the
technology is close to certain it's
known and then we have a couple other
boxes going up and to the right labeled
complicated now these we wouldn't say
are super simple but yet when it comes
to the technology and the requirements
we would say it's knowable and then you
can see kind of that green area right
there that we have labeled complex this
is where at the beginning of the project
when it comes to the actual requirements
and even the technology we don't know
there's a high level of uncertainty and
there's also the possibility of a high
level of change that might be a part of
it now let's think of two different
types of projects here um building a
building on you can't really build a
building and promised the customer that
you're going to be able to start using
components of the building in two to
four weeks it's not going to happen
you're going to have to come up with a
master plan because what goes at the top
of the building impacts what happens at
the bottom of buildings it makes sense
you know we have to figure out on the
front end what we're going to do and so
that would lend itself to the waterfall
or traditional project management
approach if we're developing a software
application there may be requirements
that need to have a solution invented
you know it's not even known how to get
something done you know in my own
project that I'm doing for my power
payment thing i have what i call my
power payment calculator
and as far as I know while components
have been addressed nobody has ever done
exactly what we're doing and so we don't
wait until everything is known before we
start the project we begin and we figure
things out as we go and when it comes to
software development we all know that
there is change from the beginning and
to the end and depending on the nature
of the marketplace and other demands
that might be placed on the project
there might even be a need for
mid-course correction meaning the end
game actually changes and in agile
that's fine in waterfall doesn't work
that way now we're going to focus on
agile in this particular session here
and to just kind of get our heads in the
game here I want to refer to a report
that was issued by the Standish Group
after they did some studies on projects
particularly software development
projects and what they discovered is
that if you are developing software
using the agile approach is going to be
three times more successful then using
the traditional waterfall approach in
fact here's a quote from the study
itself the agile process is the
universal remedy for software
development project failure software
applications developed through the agile
process have three times the success
rate of the traditional waterfall method
and a much lower percentage of time and
cost overruns and the Standish Group
defines project success is delivering
the project on time on budget with the
plan features right those are the three
components really of any project write a
schedule budget and scope now looking at
those results there in the chart there I
want to make the point here re
emphasizing that
waterfall and agile aren't competing
approaches its matching the approach to
the scenario to the project that's
important and I personally believe that
in the project management world things
are shifting and I actually believe that
to become the go-to project manager in
your organization right the the one
that's going to have a fast-track career
is going to make more money etc you
really have to have skills and knowledge
in both areas and so um like if somebody
wanted to come and work for me I would
like to see somebody that not only has a
certification and waterfall like the PMP
but I would also want to see agile
certifications like pmi-acp or exxon's
ASM or something like that because I
know that they're going to be able to
help me decide what approach is going to
be best and they have the knowledge and
skills to do that now I would imagine
that a lot of us that are on the webinar
today we deal in the IT world and we do
software development that's a large
segment of project management in the
world today so you know if in your
organization there was any equivocation
about whether or not there's a need or a
desire to shift to agile here's a great
report you can go look it up and you
could share the results of this study
with you know the suits in the
organization that might be resisting
that a bit and understand team that the
suits in an organization often resist
shifting to agile and the reason is very
simple in waterfall you have a plan up
front right on you've got your predicted
schedule you've got your predicted
budget you can measure the actuals
against it and you can say you know what
we're on budget we're on schedule or not
whatever the case may be but it's much
easier in the the minds of these folks
that wear the suits in the organization
to
to have a sense of how things are going
in agile that is not the case but what's
interesting particularly when it comes
to software development using agile
significantly improves delivering
projects on time on bread on budget with
the features that the customer wants
yeah when it comes to why an agile
adoption effort can fail you know
depending on where you go in which you
research I've seen lists as long as 11
and others that actually segmented into
different categories but here are some
of the main issues that seem to be
universal when it comes to the
challenges of transitioning to agile one
is the corporate culture itself the
organization is just not in a place
where it can change easily um older
companies that have lots of established
departments and you know things are you
know lots of traditions it's hard to
transition in anything in agile is
disrupted when it comes the project
management it does not look like
waterfall and so if the culture isn't
going to support learning or change it's
going to be a challenge also when it
comes to actually beginning the effort
of using agile the inability to get
everyone into the planning meetings is
an issue because see agile is different
than waterfall and waterfall we're going
to do the planning up front right and um
the team is going to take over and at
some point in time things shift that we
don't need everybody in all of the
various planning meetings we can just be
the team agile is different the customer
the project lead the team everybody is
supposed to be in all of the planning
meetings and if they are not the
effectiveness of the team and the
results of the project efforts go down
you're not going to get the same results
now in agile continuous improvement
is huge and one of the key things that
are a part of continuous improvement is
what we call the retrospective and if in
your organization there's the lack of or
the in effect in effective use of
retrospective you're probably not going
to successfully make the transition this
one's huge and then bats from masters or
coaches depending on which agile method
you're using we have different methods
and different titles and things for a
number of methods that all belong to the
family of agile but whoever the project
lead is if they're not good at it
they're going to tank it all they can
act one person in a project can actually
make it impossible for a project to
succeed and if you're transitioning to
agile and your first project or the
first couple of projects don't work out
so well guess what the transition
efforts over you're done and then on the
bottom one is team's lack authority and
decision-making ability so in agile
there's not that upfront planning it's
the team that makes the decisions on a
day-to-day basis on how to figure out
and deliver what the customer wants not
nobody's dictating to the team how
they're supposed to do it they have to
be empowered and they have to be
self-organizing now agile was really
developed as an answer to a number of
problems that were kind of ubiquitous
when it came to software development
projects and it was really in the 1990s
late late 1990s when agile as a separate
and distinct approach the project
management began to emerge and a group
of thought leaders in agile got together
in 2001 and they wrote what's called the
agile manifesto and I don't care which
agile certification you end up deciding
to change to pursue the agile manifesto
is going to be part of it
and here's the way it reads we are
uncovering better ways of developing
software by doing it and helping others
do it through this we have through this
work we have come the value individuals
and interactions over processes and
tools working software over
comprehensive documentation customer
collaboration over contract negotiation
responding to change over following a
plan that is while there is value in the
items on the right we value the items on
the left more now even though some of us
might be new to agile basically what
we're looking at in those two boxes on
the right that's the waterfall approach
and on the left that's the agile
approach and you can see that even agile
recognizes aspects of waterfall is being
important there's value there but the
emphasis is on the items on the left now
we mentioned on you know bad scrum
masters or bad project leads can kind of
derail the adoption of agile I grabbed
the slide from one of our trainings here
and in all of our trainings that we do
for the various agile certifications we
talked about the role of the project
lead which is in agile what we call a
servant leader the idea of a servant
leader is to empower the team and then
to assist the team in being successful
without telling the team what to do and
that can be very challenging to do but
once you get this down once you become a
genuinely good servant leader you can
get anything done because people will
respect you and they will want to have
you involved and they will be willing to
do what's necessary so in in this slide
here we talked about the characteristics
of a good and successful servant leader
starting at the top we talked about
listening and we have modules about
active listening and
empathy and we even get into emotional
intelligence and healing you know how to
serve the team and getting over
challenges you know awareness persuasion
persuasion by the way is not
dictatorship that's the ability to
empower others to see things from a
different point of view and then on
their own change their mind
conceptualization foresight stewardship
committee to the growth of people
building community and we go into all of
those and fascinating stuff now on one
of our thought leaders in agile to kind
of continue this theme right here put
together a list of agile coach or scrum
master failure modes we cover this in
our trainings but let me just look at
point out a couple here look at the top
left one the scrum master of the coach
that is the expert this is the one
that's so highly involved in the details
of the team they don't see the broader
goals and then focus on the details of
implementing the user stories that's
what the team does a good lead in an
agile project is not the expert the team
is the expert let's show you another one
here this is on the left it parked me
the right hand side the seagull this is
the project lead that kind of swoops in
to the team room and just poops all over
everything and then flies away you know
criticizes the team but then leaves
without any kind of leadership or
suggestions on how to address problems
so some of these are a little bit funny
but the point is is that you know we get
into this and you can see I think you
can get a little bit of a vision about
how being a good professional in agile
requires a lot of people skills and the
good news is is people spills or soft
skills you can learn them you can
practice them and and we cover those
kinds of things in our
various trainings I mentioned
retrospectives and I know it's a little
bit hard to see but if you can see that
kind of a figure-eight thing over there
that's what an iteration in agile looks
like an iteration is one of those time
boxed periods of time during which the
team actually creates value for the
customer I'm usually two to four weeks
sometimes one week sometimes as long as
six weeks but generally two to four
weeks and so um wonder if I have use of
my little pointer thing here we see so
if you can see my little pointer right
here if this is our starting point if
this is where we do our planning on we
go into an executing portion of an
iteration or a sprint and then we
deliver the results of that iteration or
sprint to the customer and then we go
into the retrospective a retrospective
is done at the end of every iteration
and before the next one begins and
there's five things that happen and to
be effective at retrospectives and
continuous improvement the scrum master
or the project lead has to you know help
conduct the retrospective and go through
five different phases the first one is
to set the stage get everything set up
make sure everyone knows what the rules
are in retrospective it's never about
the individual nobody is ever the focus
of blame in fact in a retrospective
there's basically three agenda items and
item one is what went well item two was
what did not go well in item three is
what are we going to do differently
going forward and so the steps would be
setting the stage gathering the date of
the results right and we can use a
number of tools for that fishbone
diagrams control charts the five wise
etc you know there's those kinds of
tools that we use in Andrew
out and then we look at what didn't work
well and we figure out what the root
causes are that leads us to what are we
going to do differently going forward
and then the retrospective is closed
like I said earlier when it comes to
transitioning to agile if you and your
team are not doing good and effective
retrospectives it's going to fail it's
not going to work now in agile there are
an array of skills and tools and
techniques many that you're actually
directly tested on in some of the
certification exams and in our trainings
we cover everything that you need to to
pass the exam in fact we go beyond that
we get into a little bit of the you know
the how you do things successfully as
opposed to just actually passing the
exam we also when it comes to our
certification preparation courses we
actually get into some of the tips and
tricks on how you actually pass the exam
as well so it's both how do you pass the
exam but how do you also become a good
whatever it is you know ACP or ASM
whatever it is you're chasing in agile
planning is a collaborative
decision-making endeavor with consensus
as the objective how do you like that
including my own self here um in agile
um well there's different types of
decision making techniques like
dictatorship a plurality flip a coin
majority on the one that we chase in
agile is consensus everybody from the
team to the project lead to the customer
to the suits everybody needs to be on
the same page so knowing how to do
participatory decision-making and how to
deal with conflict resolution how to do
effective brainstorming sessions you
know probably many of us that are here
online have been in brainstorming
sessions which were more
the disaster than they were effective
facilitating workshops and engaging with
stakeholders you know and that's broad
right not just engaging with the
customer but engaging with the suits
engaging with the team engaging with
other chemise that might be a part of
your effort so we cover all of these
things and it's such fun stuff it is so
powerful to actually acquire the skills
and be able to use the tools and
techniques to be successful in an agile
project management your life will never
be the same as you get better and better
at this now when we shift to when we
actually in the side that we're going to
shift the agile in an organization there
are two broad ways that we might go
about it we could start small that's
going to be less risky on it's going to
allow us to pen a cherry pick the team
members that we want to have and by
doing so you know we're going to
guarantee that the first project and the
first few are going to be successful and
then that disruptive radical change is
deferred so that's one approach another
approach is all in now that's going to
be quicker obviously and it's going to
be less expensive because you're not
maintaining two approaches and etc
you're all in right in so not going to
cost as much and because everybody's in
the ability to learn from each other
goes way up if you're doing the all-in
approach you know it says right here top
down by and helps i would say that
little bit differently I'd say top-down
buy-in is a must in this will be
disruptive and it's riskier but you get
it done now depending on whether or not
you start small or you do the all-in
approach you also have to decide what
patterns are you going to use to do this
for example if we look at the top left
there and you can do this in a public
display way display way so that
everybody in the organization knows that
you're doing an agile project we know
that we're doing the the shift it
clearly makes the statement that we're
committed to making the transition to
agile but that may not be the wisest way
depending on the culture of the
organization you may want to use the
stealth approach so this means that you
know with agreement you assemble a team
and you do a project using edge' and the
project is then there the results of the
project is then shared kind of after the
fact what we did look how much money we
save look how quickly we got it done
look how happy the customer is kind of a
thing when it comes to the actual
technical aspects of agile you know
test-driven development and continuous
integration and you know other things
like that how do you you know you have
to decide do you introduce all of them
right away or do you introduce them in
stages so again the culture is an issue
you know what is going to serve you well
now once you start and you need to go
from you know one teen one project to
the whole organization embracing edge
others two approaches you can split and
see so that's where members from an
existing team are used to seed other
teams or you can grow and split so you
take a team and you grow it and then you
split it and then each of those new
teams grow and split grown split that's
going to be faster and it's probably
going to be more more culturally
disruptive but you can get through it
faster that way so again you know if it
comes to transitioning to
agile it's not just they flip the switch
okay we're going to do agile now on
those that lead it have to put a lot of
thought into it and work on the strategy
in fact a transition to agile itself is
a um a project itself let's see here oh
I see a question that popped up here how
is all in lower costs the all in being a
lower cost is simply because you're not
having to maintain two different
structures and approaches at the same
time you may still need to do training
and waterfall we're doing training and
agile you may have to be different
reporting things and use different tools
so you know making the commitment
shifting is there may be some you know
some higher costs on the the front end
to just shift the agile but overall
that's proven to be less expensive
getting back to the idea of doing a
project for the transition itself this
is what you might do organizationally
you know on the left you might get a
sponsor you know get one of the suits to
act as the product owner or the customer
for the transition efforts you might
even form a committee or a team and give
it a cool name like Enterprise
transition committee and then actually
create a product backlog for it product
backlogs consist of items which are
really the list of features or things
that need to be done so the backlog is
actually the scope of the project if you
will also you know another consideration
is going to be what project you should
use as your first project and here we've
got you know a number of considerations
if you look at the upside down triangle
that's the project size and you can see
that you don't want a project that's too
small because it will be
deemed insignificant well you haven't
really proven that agile works is
anybody going to interrupt you just for
a second I don't know if everybody else
the screen is the same but mine isn't
showing an upside down triangle is just
showing a bunch of a big square of weird
patterns really so you don't see a
triangle right here well now it's coming
in when you pulled your mouse over oh I
have somebody else is saying there's is
fine so it's just on my screen for some
reason I don't know why maybe because
i'm on the panelists I'd nurse okay so
yeah so came up weird on mine sorry
everybody for the interruption let me go
ahead and give it back to Jeff here we
go yes the comments coming and they can
see it well Richard thanks for doing
that because if you aren't seeing it
it's likely that others aren't
especially had this many people on a
webinar so um that upside-down triangle
the project size is an issue right so
you don't want it to be too small or
it's deemed insignificant but you don't
want it to be a big one either because
it's just too risky and all eyes are
going to be on it and they're going to
be critical if you look at the box the
rectangle that is horizontal there
that's labeled duration and you want to
pick something kind in the middle you
don't want a super short project and you
don't want one that's too long I'm short
again is going to be just too
insignificant and then long it's going
to take too long for the results to be
in and you'll lose momentum you won't
gain momentum there's one that's labeled
one rectangle labeled importance so
again you've got to pick the right
project there now don't pick the most
critical project in your organization
but be a little bit bold right pick one
that's not unimportant pick one that is
important and then the last one is
business sponsorship meaning the suits
right which ones wit projects are they
behind which one did they have the most
interest in and that you're going to
favor you know a lot of support from the
suits and you know certainly you don't
want to pick one
that isn't very popular and you still
want to avoid the ones that have the
most visibility you know be smart about
it so that kind of pentagon there in the
middle is the sweet spot for choosing
the right project for a transition now
we have covered a whole bunch of stuff
and there's no way that we can get
deeply into all of it here but can I
just can I take us back to this one
slide and I just want to tell you based
on my own experience the things that I
believe are the things that we have to
focus most on um I believe that it
starts right here with the project lead
um being a coach if you're doing extreme
programming or a scrum master if you're
doing scrum you've got to have the right
person and that right person has to
become a servant leader and that servant
leader then needs to create the
environment if you look at the one below
that where the team is empowered and
genuinely has the ability to decide for
itself how they're going to deliver the
value to the customer now once you have
that kind of environment there you've
got a good project lead that understands
agile can be a mentor and to be a coach
and genuinely honors the empowerment of
the team then you've got to deal with
continuous improvement which are the
retrospective and the ability to have
effective planning meetings I think
culture is an issue but I think that's
navigable you know you just figure out
what it is and you pick the best way to
do it but these four items right here
like I said before I've seen rather long
list but to me these are the key ones
right here
and the good news is is that in any of
our trainings we get into this not just
because it's important for you as
project managers in your organization
but you know what this is where you get
a lot of questions you know what the
planning meetings look like how long
should they be who should be there what
do retrospectives look like when are
they held how long are they held who's
there etc and then you'll get questions
about you know what does a good a July
you know a servant leader what kind of
skills you'll get scenario questions you
know if the team is experiencing this
problem what should the scrum master do
and then and then you get questions
about that the dynamics of the team and
how to lead without being a dictator
seeing waterfall it's very top-down
right you know you got the plan the
project manager you know orchestrates
manages you know keeps everybody
directed make sure that you know using
some kind of work authorization system
none of that exists in agile it is
bottom-up and good effective agile
implementation honors the self
empowerment of the team so that's just
kind of a wrap up summary there I want
to now get back to where we were and
point out that one of the things that we
have at simply learners we call our
project management expert masters
program and Richard might get into this
a little bit more but what this is is a
collection of trainings and
certifications that we believe will
empower you to become the go-to project
manager in your organization and so it's
a blend of things like waterfall project
management agile project management I
teal foundation some six sigma training
things like that we're in today's world
you can't just be so specialized and say
you know all i do is waterfall or all i
do is agile
and I don't care about you know
operations and the world's not like that
anymore and so we've created this unique
masters program so that you could
fast-track your career by over a
relatively short period of time acquire
the certifications and the skills and
tools and techniques that you need to be
successful and I want to just a word
about these credentials that are out
there you know it simply learn you know
we say get ahead get certified and can I
just tell you i am not a fan of
standardized testing as a little bitta
mattel someone's going to perform in the
real world but you know what it's the
best thing we have and so acquiring
credentials is a big deal and um now you
have to be able to promote yourself and
you have to be able to get good at
things but that's where you start you
get the credentials and so that's what
our masters program is about is getting
the right credentials in acquiring the
right skills to get ahead and simply
learn has a couple of very unique things
that are world class we have our
learning management system and this is
online content with practice exams that
behave like the real exams and tips and
tricks on how to prepare for and pass
exams and then we have a community that
we call simply talk where all of our
instructors as well as our professionals
that are engaged with us can post
questions get answers and collaborate
everything from how to get ready to pass
an exam to actual skills tools and
techniques all the way to networking
about job opportunities and things like
that and then um let me just as
impacting the the microphone back to
richer
word just post this right here that you
can find out a lot of this stuff that
simply learned that Congress give us a
call intact one of our you know career
consultants to help create a path that
works best for you and so with that
Richard I'm going to pass the microphone
back over to you okay Jeff and go ahead
and stay on because I have some great
questions people are asking on there I
am going to take over the screen here
just for the first five minutes or so so
because we do have a poll that I launch
a great place this will allow us to send
you more information and find out
exactly what different people are
looking for while the poll is up let's
go ahead and I'll take the first
question from Jeremy myself will the
presentation be available for download
the answer is yes we do record all our
webinars they do go back and check them
and format them and make sure that
everything is right before they post
them so it does take up to 12 hours to
get a copy of the webinar if you go to
simply learn calm under support send a
request note and then they'll send you
out the link to download the webinar so
you can view it yourself let's see we
have some other great questions on here
what are the documentation required to
shift to project a project agile look at
the documentation do you guys work with
is there a documentation library and
agile I know in I told there is for IT
and stuff like that so in our ASM
training that's agile scrum master we
devote one whole module to the
transition and in there there is the
documentation that covers everything
from organizational structure to
patterns two approaches to how you deal
with resistors you know resistance you
know we help you categorize people into
four different quadrants and how to
address it so anyway one whole module
there with a ton of resources that not
only
dress questions that you'll get on the
exam but a lot of the how-to and the
tools and the documentation is that you
would use in a transition um if you if
I'm if it's okay with you if you are in
a position where your organization is
thinking about embarking on an agile
transition effort or you're early in one
the ASM course is the one that addresses
that better than any of the others that
we have you know each course each
credential has its own strengths the
asn.1 is very strong when it comes to
agile adoption Oh excellent and that
actually leads right into the next
question because you're talking about
the ASM certification program the next
question is more in real life and I'm
going to actually change the question of
it from cart I hope I say the name right
karti it when you're in real life and
you're switching over what kind of cost
is associated with the business in
changing too or shifting to the agile
since there are shifting the whole
entire organization or where they're
working on shifting individual projects
over so that's the big question isn't it
um there is without a doubt some upfront
costs that are involved even if it's
just training costs but there's usually
other things as well you've got your HR
department that needs to shift because
you know titles change roles change how
people's performance is measured changes
but here's the bottom line if we go back
to that Standish Group study eventually
and sooner than later the payback period
point is reached and you actually begin
to save money you become more productive
and then it's from that point on the
company is saving money and actually
making more money it's kind of a
two-pronged thing you know two sides of
the same coin when waterfall
organization shifts the agile for its
software development projects
the cost of actually completing the
project's team the project lead etc all
changes and in the costs go down there
are some front upfront costs like we
mentioned but then also because you're
producing higher quality software and
you're doing it faster than ever before
the company also makes more money so
while there can be a learning curve in
some challenges that need to be
navigated there is no question and not
just the Standish Group but there are
boatloads of studies that verify that
making the shift to agile for software
development projects is really the only
way to go you got to do it excellent um
thank you Jeff I'm always learning
something it's always like a bottom line
for any business I've worked with a lot
of small businesses and they are always
asking well what'swhat's going to be my
underlying cost it's so hard to answer
that question in yeah can I jump in oh
geez also Richard you know another thing
about agile is if anybody knows about
the history of agile you know that it
originated for small projects and small
teams but because of the advent of
different tools in maturation of the
actual profession we now talk about
enterprise edge and there are techniques
and approaches that we cover in our
earnings on how to scale agile in other
words how do you use the agile
techniques which were originally
developed for small project small teams
for an enterprise sized software
development project X I've had a little
bit of that myself yes that I find that
very true could you go a little bit into
the difference between CSM an agile
scrum master and why a person would want
to look at a certification one or the
other as far as I could I believe it's
from birra as far as a job field if
they're looking for further their career
so first of all let's make sure we're
clear on the acronyms for everybody CSM
is certified scrum master ASM is agile
scrum master both of them are
credentials that are offered by
different organizations now here's the
thing agile is a family of methods scrum
is one of the methods and it is true
that scrum is the single most popular
method for agile project management over
fifty percent of all projects you agile
projects use scrum but scrum is a little
bit more like a framework and it
actually borrows tools and techniques
from other agile methods like X and lean
and Kanban and crystal and others and so
if you get your CSM which is valuable
its focus is only on scrum the agile
scrum master is about all of the egg
wash and say all about the main agile
methods with an emphasis on scrum and in
my own personal experiences I
transitioned from being just you know
the PMP the waterfall approach in the
agile I have found high value in a
broader exposure to the family of agile
than just focusing on scruff now i'm not
i'm trying to give both approaches there
do because there's value in both if it
were me I would make sure i have my PMP
or prints too depending where you are on
the world in the world but I'm in the US
and so the PMP is the big waterfall one
and then I would either do pmi-acp or
ASM because both of those have a broader
approach they still cover scrum and then
you would have with either the pnp and
the ACP or the AS
and you would have the core credentials
and the core skills in order to be
versatile enough to be the kind of
project manager that your organization
needs as opposed to being siloed is just
waterfall or siloed is just scrum that's
what my recommendation would be at least
ok excellent and since we're on the
topic of you know like we've done
classrooms and what certifications
people would want to go through what
about afterward if you're already em
certified in PMP pmi-acp certified and
you're looking to move beyond that too
and i apologize i'm not familiar with
all the acronyms I'm glad I'm learning a
lot here today asq six sigma black belt
certification can you talk a little bit
about that and what comes after or other
things a branch out of the scrum
certifications and the yeah my GP after
you got your waterfall credential and
you've got you know your agile
credential whichever ones you choose to
do then I would shift to getting your
ITIL foundation certification this is um
how you kind of link your agile project
management with you know the the
operations end of things if you will the
IT department and how you do more
effective transitions etc and then I
would also consider getting your six
sigma green belt certification there's
other six sigma certifications but the
green belts the one that fits best with
where you are as an agile project
manager now and so I would at least
focus on those four areas for
credentials I don't think that there's
well let me say that differently I also
think there's value in like getting your
ACP and your ASM for example because
they both are well they're both on agile
they both have their
front strings and but now once you have
your credentials in these four areas
then I think you get some more hands-on
training maybe you'll want to get some
training on how to use Microsoft Project
or maybe you want to get into some
specific skill training on how to be a
servant leader you know things like that
which you know speak to kind of the
ongoing skill improvement part of things
which you got to do anyway right because
these credentials have a sunset you know
they're good for two years or three
years depending on who you go with and
during that period of time you have to
do continuing education excellent
switching gears a little bit here kind
of maybe a more personal question for
you people are asking how do you become
an instructor for PMP or how do you
become get a position as a coaching role
that's from Julia and then also from the
cottage asking about you know if you're
going to do if you're going to become an
instructor and you're going to work on
coaching people and going in and helping
people what was your path or other path
you've seen that help you get there as
far as that so you know what's really
interesting is for me I'm an accidental
project manager I had a buddy at compact
computers and that goes back a few years
because compacts or emerged with HP a
number of years ago but he called me up
out of the blue and said Jeff we've got
this joint effort going on with
Microsoft and we meet somebody to lead
it I think you'd be great I'm like okay
I'll do that and and so I did all kinds
of planning and reporting and all kinds
of things the project managers do but I
had no idea that there was any formal
project management out there and so when
I decided to get my P&P that was the
first time I ever heard of the project
management institutes first time ever
heard about the pen back and that was
what washed me into this path of being a
certified project manager a number of
areas personally I've always loved being
a presenter and a trainer not so much
because I like getting in front of a
group of people I get nervous about that
but I love assisting people in improving
and when you're a presenter you have
that opportunity to be able to engage
with people and by you know fective
engagement you can actually identify
what's going to serve them the best and
then you address it so for me I'm in
making that shift the credentials come
first if you want to be a PMP trainer
you go get your PP if you want to you
know do ASM classes you will get your
ASM or your ACP or whatever it is and
then in order to be a good presenter you
have to have depth and we've all been to
presentations where the instructor was
kind of shallow in his or her knowledge
right and you ask a question in they
don't really know the answer or you can
tell you've kind of reached the limits
of their knowledge and experience so
being out there and doing it yourself
and studying and acquiring more
knowledge and information is critical
and you know and even you know learning
how to be a presenter taking some
classes on things like that is going to
help you and if you have that kind of
interest I encourage you to pursue it I
don't know if you'd end up with us it's
simply learned or even in project
management but the greatest thing about
being a presenter and instructor is you
always learn more than you can ever
teach others and so you become better
and you become well you become a better
person I guess that's what I'm trying to
say anyway that was maybe a longer
answer than you wanted but I love it and
you're interested would let the be of
assistance excellent excellent I think
we had a Nicklaus pointed out that if
you actually want to go teach at say a
university then you'd also have to have
a PhD at the university level since
you're learning
too if they want to see that so a lot of
it depends on who you're working with
and where you're coaching certainly in
my own business arena my work working
with smaller business I already have a
connection with these businesses so when
I go and I talked to people and I'm not
a project manager okay I work in the IT
side they come to me and we talked and
if it's a fit then I come in there and i
might do tutorials for some of the
clients or something like that on the
software we're working with let's see we
got here we have more questions on how
it fits for an IT infrastructure
projects is the best fit now here's the
thing you know Lee open you the type of
project that you're talking about is
going to lend itself to a blend here so
the agile part is going to be helpful
when it comes to the discovery of
solutions and you know figuring out how
to deliver incremental e which is
critical for those kinds of projects but
when it comes to the reporting and the
testing and the identification of scope
and things like that that's where some
of the waterfall skills tools and
techniques would come in there so if I
were in an organization that was dealing
with those kinds of projects my number
one emphasis would be on agile but I
would be eager to find those that had a
background in waterfall as well leo
excellent excellent I'm going to go
ahead and close the poll if that's up on
your screen here the next minute and
we'll go a few minutes over as they have
a couple more questions coming in one of
them from Ramya do these courses and I
guess referring to simply learn do they
provide a certificate and what is that
certificate mean and what exactly does
it mean to come in and go through these
programs and I know a lot of us could
actually
take another test become fully certified
can you explain a little bit of how
those fit together yeah so that's what
we're really doing here together today
right we're trying to figure out what's
the best thing to do in what are our
organizations going to look to for
validation that you're a good hire or
the right fit for a project or whatever
so all of our courses have a completion
certificate um frankly completion
certificates from courses I don't think
carry a ton of weight but they're the
stepping stone to getting the actual
credential the credentials are what in
my opinion are the most sought-after
evidence that organizations rely on when
they look at people as potential hires
for advancement for responsibilities etc
so the credentials are huge the course
completion certificates particularly
with the exam prep courses not so much
when you get into more vertical type
trainings you know Microsoft Project and
things like that then course completion
certificates are helpful but can I also
say that just owning a credential
acquiring one isn't magic you know you
know I told you I had a buddy that hired
me at compaq um later he left compaq and
I have transitioned into doing exam prep
training for project management and he
had gotten remarried and so now it's a
yours mine and ours a big family and
he's like Jeff he says I'm not making
enough money now that I'm married I've
got to figure out how to make some more
money and I think I need to go get my
PMP credential you know you do in a
class that I can go to and so I said
well yeah and so we got him signed up he
went to the class he passed the exam on
his first attempt and then here's what
he did romneya and he gets back to work
he sends an email out
key people in his organization say I
just want to let you know I just
successfully acquired my PMP credential
and I learned some things and he
mentioned a couple of the things you
know 34 of things that are part of the
PMP that he knew were relevant for his
organization and so he did some self
promotion within two weeks he was given
more responsibility and a raise that met
his needs so credentials are good course
certificate completion certificates are
good but it's your career and you've got
the market yourself and so the
certificates and the credentials give
you tools but you got to work them
excellent we in thank you Jeff thank you
that was actually a helpful even beyond
project management it's also true of
just about any industry any company
nowadays romeo says thank you you're
welcome romneya I appreciate the
question we are at the end of the hour
gone over a little bit so we're going to
go ahead and close the webinar for today
quick note you can go to simply learn
com there was a few questions we weren't
able to get to please go there under the
community they have the open forum at
the top where you can go in and ask
questions and it's open to everybody if
you are simply learn member and
registered you can go under simply talk
that's the private forum for the
organization definitely post your
questions there we have experts to go
and look at those you're welcome Julia
that great to have you Jeff did you want
to add anything on here before we close
the session I do I want to thank you all
for being a part of this I know that
it's a commitment to spend an hour
together on something like this I hope
that the things that I've shared are
beneficial and I hope our paths cross
again and I wish you the very best not
only in your project management efforts
but in life excellent I'm going to go
and thank everybody for being here we
look forward to seeing you in our
classes and
thank you Jeff for a wonderful session I
greatly appreciate you being here and
joining us and taking time and we look
forward to the next webinar with you
thank you
you